savon est bien plus dangereux que tu ne
le penses surin a acheté un tout neuf au
petit artisan du coin et tu utilises
sous la douche d'un coup tout ton corps
devient rouge et se mettent à te brûler
comme si tu étais aspergée d'acide vient
en fait de te laver avec de la soude
caustique carton savons a été mal
préparée il ya plein de tuto sur youtube
et c'est très simple à faire tu mélanges
de la soude ou de la potasse caustique
avec une substance grasse il d'olive
graisses animales beurre de karité tout
est possible au niveau moléculaire se
produira alors ce qu'on appelle la
saponification le problème c'est que ces
vidéos n'insiste pas assez sur une
dernière étape cruciale le séchage la
soul mais longtemps à devenir
inoffensive en dessous de 4 semaines tu
as une arme chimique entre les mains en
2021 en inde une famille a acheté un kit
pour faire du savon maison le petit
garçon de 5 ans va ingéré le savons
encore humide en pensant à un bonbon son
intestin a été dissous il a eu besoin
d'une lourde chirurgie et ne peut
toujours pas manger correctement il
existe dans ton quotidien beaucoup
d'objets avec ce genre de petit secret
mortel qui pourrait te dégoûter de leur
utilisation alors voyons ensemble ces
objets tueur d'hôtes au quotidien quel
objet de ta maison pourrait te tuer je
suis en soirée chez des amis la lumière
s'éteint et tout le monde se met à
craquer des petits bâtonnets brillant ce
sont des glo stick zoo l'air d'être des
petits jouets tout innocent mais je vous
déconseille de laisser s'échapper le
liquide qui coule à l'intérieur pour
votre sécurité lorsque vous le crack est
une réaction se produit dans le tube
c'est la chimie luminescence est l'un
des actifs impliqués et le balade de 10
buts il cette molécule est assez
impressionnante par exemple elle permet
à une bouteille en plastique de devenir
un sac si cette molécule a été bannie
des produits cosmétiques en europe 2015
c'est pas pour rien c'est toxique pour
toi et l'environnement il permet
d'ajouter de la flexibilité aux produits
ou encore de créer des explosifs mais
qu'est ce qui se passe si tu fait chuter
le bostik ta peau va te brûler tes yeux
aussi situe en aval et c'est ta bouche
et la gorge qui vont prendre cher autant
te dire que si tu envoies un éclatant
soirée bat directement le jeter à la
poubelle un autre objet plus ancien mais
qui a fait autant parler de lui c'est le
thermomètres au mercure de tes grands
parents si on utilise ce méthane liquide
c'est parce qu'ils se contractent et se
dilate facilement en fonction de la
température
le problème c'est si tu brises le
thermomètre dedans il y a environ 3
grammes de mercure et là tu as intérêt à
fuir anorexie problèmes cardiaques
cécité surdité insomnie fatigue la dose
létale et de deux guilluy g pour une
personne de 70 kg un thermomètre peut
achever s'il tombe et se casse au sol
des vapeurs toxiques voire pire la pièce
est empoisonné en 2015 en inde un enfant
de deux ans a été admis à l'hôpital deux
heures après avoir ingéré le mercure
d'un thermomètre quelques vomissements
et une coupe à l'âge où ont été reportés
mais heureusement il s'en est sorti
indemne d'autres n'ont pas été aussi
chanceux aujourd'hui ces thermomètres
sont bannis jugé trop dangereux on les a
remplacés par des thermomètres au
gallium où en est un des métaux bien
moins nocifs et tout autant manipulable
certains objets sont encore bien plus
effrayant à cause de leur radioactivité
voyez les panneaux excite qu'on voit
dans tous les films pourquoi c'est
lumineux sont grâce au tritium un
isotope radioactif de l'hydrogène qui
brille naturellement après je vous
rassure ça fait peur mais le tritium est
assez courant dans la nature et ne
causent pas vraiment de risque pour la
santé humaine ce qui n'est clairement
pas le cas de certains détecteurs de
fumée bagne en france et en allemagne
depuis 2011 parce qu'ils contiennent de
l'américium 241 et du radium 226 et eux
ils ne joue pas dans la cour des enfants
ils sont extrêmement radioactif 16 micro
curie de l'américium 241 par kg ont
provoqué une aplasie cellulaire chez des
animaux cobayes dit autrement ils ont
commencé à se désagréger vivant
heureusement dans les détecteurs de
fumée on est loin de ces doses mortelles
à peine 0,3 microgrammes tu risques pas
grand chose par sécurité aujourd'hui on
préfère maintenant des détecteurs
optiques ou thermique au dix neuvième
siècle on faisait pire avec de la
verrine en oural in du vert dans lequel
on a mis de l'uranium alors sur le
papier ça donne un joli vert fluo mais
quand les quantités radioactifs monté
jusqu'à 25 % pour certaines pièces
c'était bien trop dangereux surtout que
tu manges et dedans vous pouvez encore
en trouver sur ebay à de faibles
quantités et les prix sont même assez
abordable même si les produits toxiques
du passé sont remplacés par des matières
plus saine tu peux aussi trouvé dans ta
cuisine des armes toxiques par exemple
une poêle anti adhésif en téflon tu peut
la transformer en gaz mortel juste en la
faisant chauffer de 160° exactement faut
quand même avoir un four très puissant à
cette température le thé fond de ta poil
produit des émanations de gaz fluorés et
là ça sent pas bon pour toi le
tétrachloréthylène est cancérigène et le
perfluorooctane est dix fois plus
toxique que les gaz utilisé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale les produits
cosmétiques aux ingrédients terrifiant
est ce que tu as déjà lu les ingrédients
aux doutes aux shampoings c'est vraiment
incompréhensible regarde cette liste
d'ingrédients qui donne mal au crâne
pour parler d'eau de conservateurs ou de
parfum genre à quoi pour parler de
sérieux c'est quoi ce camouflage claqué
certains labels utilise le terme odeur
ou saveur à la place d'ingrédients
potentiellement toxique problème c'est
que la loi impose de lister des
ingrédients qu'à partir de 1974 et des
lobbys puissants empêchent les
consommateurs d'avoir accès à toutes les
informations
voyons ça sur le rouge à lèvres encore
aujourd'hui il y à du plomb de l'arsenic
et du mercure sur les lèvres de vos
chéris une femme un gère en moyenne 24
mg de ces métaux par jour ça paraît
faible mais c'est énorme ça bloque tard
aux productions affaibli ton système
immunitaire augmente la nervosité cette
abondance de métaux toxiques a conduit à
beaucoup de drames dans le passé comme
l'étude de 2007 en iran qui révèle que
sur 33 rouge à lèvres 60% contiennent de
grosse dose de plomb c'est un complot
qui cherchent à nous empoisonner
pourquoi [ __ ] ça dans les produits du
quotidien la réponse est un peu
décevante ce sont des pigments c'est eux
qui permettent à thon rouge à lèvres
d'avoir cette couleur brillante tu payes
ta beauté au prix de ta santé faut
souffrir pour être beau nom dans 6 g de
rouge à lèvres tu as 60 microgrammes de
métal la dose fatale et de 0,2 gramme de
plomb ce qui revient à manger 33000
rouge à lèvres des quantités assez
négligeable loin de ce que tu absorbe ne
serait ce qu'en mangeant du poisson le
mercure lui sert de conservateurs
évidemment bien cachés sous ce terme un
autre exemple du genre le terme
fragrance si vous le voyez dans les
ingrédients bas fuyez se cache en fait
ici des composés à base de salades des
molécules dérivés d'acides problèmes de
peau allergies cancers 26 substances ont
l'obligation d'être précisés mais
certaines peuvent être cachés sous ce
joli mot comme ce n'est pas vendeur les
marques préfèrent les dissimuler dès que
possible autre exemple de produits
toxiques les parabènes tout un panel de
molécules dont le but est d'éviter le
développement de bactéries dans des
produits comme pour le lait ils sont
bourrés de perturbateurs endocriniens ce
sont tous les dérivés d'esther sous
forme de sel blanc des fins cristaux qui
ont introduit dans les formules
cosmétiques peuvent affecter ton sang et
ton système digestif briser aussi ton
cycle reproductif après il faut savoir
garder raison prenez les acides dans ton
shampoing ça fait peur de se mettre ça
sur le crâne on est d'accord en fait ils
ont un effet contre intuitif ils sont là
pour que ton shampoing ne soit pas
corrosif a produit peut être soit si
comme le citron soit basiques comme la
soude deux sont tout aussi dangereux
leur équilibre et le point de sécurité
un ph neutre quoi ces aliments qui
pourrait te tuer si je disais que ton
petit déjeuner café fruits les omelette
aux pommes de terre était peut-être une
bombe toxiques commençons avec le café
19 mars 2010neuf sofia bening et
retrouvée morte dans sa chambre elle a
des 24 ans dépressif mais
particulièrement doué à l'école
l'étudiante a utilisé ses connaissances
en biomédecine pour commander un café en
ligne est ingéré trois fois la dose
létale pour mettre fin à ses jours 10
grammes seulement de cette molécule sont
suffisants pour te tuer c'est ça la
caféine l'a2 à ne pas dépasser pour un
humain et de 400 mg par jour au delà tu
vas passer un sale quart d'heure
nervosité extrême accélération du
battement cardiaque et perturbations du
système sanguin après ingestion tu va
produire de la noradrénaline et certains
enzymes qui vont mettre le chaos dans
ton coeur la pression de ton sang va
diminuer jusqu'à ce que ton coeur ne
répond plus à cause de l'overdose les
effets sont très proches de la cocaïne
et ça a été prouvé sur des souris on
leur a retiré génétiquement une protéine
responsable de la dépendance aux drogues
dont la cocaïne et on s'est rendu compte
qu'elle ne réagissait plus au café non
plus les deux passent par ce même
circuit nerveux pour agir sur le corps
si tu prends une dose létale prépare-toi
30 tasse de café en attente très court
si tu arrives à tenir autant de tâches
sans être dégoûté tu pourra apprécier
les vomissements les douleurs
abdominales ta conscience altérée
progressivement puis ta mort la théine
buté est tout autant toxiques en fait
c'est exactement la même molécule mais
là on parle de 420 tasse de thé vert si
tu veux passer l'armé à gauche si on
passe maintenant sur la corbeille de
fruits de ta cuisine c'est tout aussi
effrayant on te dit pourtant que c'est
bon pour ta santé ça aide au bon
développement du corps c'est l'aliment
parfait comme le fruit défendu du jardin
d'éden ils cachent bien leur jeu et si
je disais que les pommes que tu achète
au supermarché contiennent du cyanure à
peine quelques milligrammes peuvent se
mettre en pls seulement 250 pour tuer un
homme en bonne santé à peine la taille
d'un petit comprimé doliprane dans les
pépins et les noyaux des fruits et des
légumes tu trouves un composé chimique à
la mie câline c'est lui qui se
transforme en cyanure comment la mie
câline est décomposé dans ton petit
intestin à cause de l'enzyme des tags
corinne base pour 500 mg d'amik d'aline
tu reçois 30 mg de cyanure par chance un
pépin ça libère moins d'un milligramme
de cyanure tu devras donc mâché entre 80
et 5 sans pépin pour développer une
intoxication comme pour le café c'est la
dose qui fait le poison enfin
les aliments le verre de lait dans les
années 80 en suède et publié une étude
qui montre que trop de lait augmenterait
le risque de mortalité de fractures plus
de trois verres par jour et tu as un
risque presque doublé de décès de
maladie cardiovasculaire 44 % de risques
en plus de développer des cancers par
rapport à quelqu'un qui boirait moins
d'un verre par jour à la base les là
pour la croissance des veaux c'est
bourrés d'hormones pour prendre près
d'un kilo par jour or vous l'avez
remarqué on n'est pas des veaux ça
n'empêche que ces molécules ne sont pas
totalement incompatible avec nous comme
des perturbateurs endocriniens
court-circuitant ton propre système
hormonal à des faux dévots ça peut faire
grandir des tumeurs cancéreuses voilà
pourquoi certains chercheurs parlent
d'un poison blanc après soyons réalistes
en termes de quantité un verre de lait
c'est 2 nanogrammes d'hormones hausse
trogen près de 200 fois moins que la
production du corps d'une femme par jour
il faudrait en boire entre 35 et 16
millions pour égaler cette production
fait tu risques de mourir d'un mal de
ventre que d'une overdose dans le genre
malformations étrange rien ne peut
battre les pommes de terre tu es là je
suis achète un sac de patates et tu en
utilise un peu et tu laisses le reste
dans le sac une semaine après des
petites excroissances vertes ont déjà
commencé à remplir la surface de la
pomme de terre ce sont des yeux ne les
mange surtout pas dedans de la soul and
in de l'achat konin les deux vont
détruire les barrières protectrices des
cellules vomissements douleurs à
l'abdomen ou encore des diarrhées ces
toxines sont des vrais démons 300 mg de
solanin seulement pour te tuer dans une
pomme de terre saine tueur en a très peu
0,2 g exactement mais dans ces
excroissances ça peut monter jusqu'à 50
mg dans le sud de londres en 1979 une
école de jeunes garçons on a fait les
frais de cet aliment soixante dix huit
enfants ont subi les symptômes d'outreau
subi une fièvre violente de la
convulsion et même des comas une chaîne
youtube a même tenté l'expérience de
consommation abusive pour vous boire 11
litres d'eau en deux heures manger des
pommes de terre périmés tout est
terrifiant à chaque fois toutes les
conséquences sont terribles et patients
perdent bessens voix des parties de leur
corps gonflés des infections se
développe en hauteur de leurs organes
des aliments sains qui deviennent des
cauchemars ce qu'il faut retenir de
cette vidéo ce n'est pas la peur mais la
raison vous ne pouvez pas échapper aux
produits chimiques même dans la nature
la chine est absolument partout autour
de nous dans une plante qui pousse ou à
la formation des nuages il faut
simplement être informés des risques et
des quantités espérer que les industries
le soit encore plus pour nous prévenir
de mise en danger inutile comme tout
dans la vie rien n'est dangereux s'il
est consommé à juste de l'eau
[Musique]